der freiheitsgedanke inwieweit bringen
denn auch diese jungen leute mit die
jungen parlamentarier die da jetzt ein
ziel das ist ja wirklich eine
zeitenwende die da jetzt passiert was
sind das für menschen die jetzt ins
parlament kommen auf eine seite es sind
sehr viele leute nicht nur bei uns aber
vor allem bei uns die tatsächlich
politisiert worden sind weil sie sehen
dass der planet vor die hunde geht die
sehen dass die dieses hier damit der
wissenschaft beschäftigt haben und die
folgen des klimawandels sehen aber auch
zunehmend begreifen und auch und quasi
den älteren immer wieder volker und was
das eigentlich bedeutet für alles andere
auch wir haben die letzten jahre zu
wenig aus unserer sicht aber vor
prävention geld ausgegeben jetzt wären
wir immer mal für anpassung ausgeben
müssen und es wird wachsen und wachsen
weil es viel teures prävention und
dieses geld wenn wir aus allen anderen
lebensbereichen abziehen müssen damit
wir überlebensfähig bleiben aus dem
sozialbereich aus der digitalisierung
aus dem gesamten infrastruktur bereich
beispielsweise das ist natürlich
verheerend und diese leute wollen dass
das auch sie wenn sie mal die
verantwortung gross bekommen dass sie
irgendetwas noch gestalten können und
nicht einfach nur dasitzen und sagen das
ganze geld was da der staat wirtschaftet
oder die leute wirtschaft die brita
privatsektor wirtschaft geht nur noch
darin dass wir dass wir irgendwie
anpassungsmaßnahmen haben damit wir
jetzt nicht wo die hunde geht harry
potter jetzt kommt man ja zum kern der
sache die in den zielen sind wir uns
alle einig lima klima beeinflussen aber
wie nicht jetzt wird müssen die
wahrheiten auf den tisch legen wahlkampf
weitgehend aus die frage ist mit wem
kann man das umsetzt ja mit wem kann man
was um sehr genau und da ist glaube ich
diese emphase die in ihren keller in
ihrer mitglied so steckt und die eine
gewisse nüchternheit genau
marktorientierte lüsternheit der fdp
eine gute kombination genau deswegen und
lasst uns genau darüber jetzt sprechen
es gibt einen
gibt mehrere interessante töne dazu der
eine ist von christian lindner der in
der immer noch sehr sehenswerten
dokumentation von stephan lamby dass man
versucht hat zu erklären erklärt hat wo
die großen wirklich kulturellen
unterschiede sind zwischen grünen und
liberalen hört mal kurz rein so jetzt
die frage wie soll das funktionieren
ich hab ich meine eher in frage kommen
sozialisten gleichheits fanatiker
die wir ja die wir jetzt da hinten sehen
herr wissing der generalsekretär der
saar-fdp der schon zweimal eine ampel in
rheinland-pfalz eingetütet also der weiß
wie das geht aber trotzdem bei der
aussage wie soll das gehen
ehrlich gesagt ich habe bei den
ausführungen von christian linden davon
nämlich nicht weiß von meinen sie sehen
wahrscheinlich vor da war ja vor der
araber aber nicht so furchtbar lange her
jetzt aber ich verstehe diese hat sagte
die stehen den frontal stellung ich weiß
nicht warum wir werden nicht alles über
den markt regulieren können
aber daran glaubt ja ja die gletscher
haben keinen marktwert die muss man
trotzdem schützen die artenvielfalt hat
einen ganz vielen stellen kein markt
wird trotzdem muss man sie schützen ist
zentral für das rettern des planeten man
ist jetzt so pathetisch sagen darf und
gleichzeitig werden wir ohne dass wir
den privatsektor mit reinziehen ohne
dass wir gespräche führen mit der
wirtschaft ohne dass wir auch
technologie anwenden natürlich
nirgendwohin kommen das heißt alles was
er geschrieben hat an zwei seiten
gehören zusammen und naja alles machen
müssen damit wir verraten wo ja naja
also theoretisch kann man das natürlich
so sehen aber er die position der fdp
ist doch klar und die ist doch
fundamental anders als ihre position
annalena baerbock hat doch den satz
gesagt verbote haben immer zu innovation
geführt na ja auch ja aber aus ja
auch sagen sie sich selbstverständlich
das ist sicher sagte er arbeite ständig
sofort den blutdruck in ungeahnte höhen
treiben sie denn wir hatten eine gut
wieder der vorwurf der verbots partei
und soja also das kann man das kann man
da irgendwo drauf lösen also wo der
markt funktioniert soll er funktionieren
ja sobald er überhaupt funktioniert
würde ich sagen okay und die
selbstverantwortung des menschen aber er
funktioniert eben nicht überall also
im auto eingeführt wurde gab es ein
riesen der sicherheitsgurt wir haben die
leute gesagt viele leute gesagt er denke
nicht daran und da wurde strafbewehrt ja
ging ich anders ja oder ja ich hab den
katalysator auspuff auto eingeführt also
umweltminister und das bier und die
regel die wir damals aufgestellt haben
führte zu innovationen das gibt es eben
was hat sie benutzen das wort regel
annalena baerbock hat das wort verboten
er benutzt also
gemeinte frage wie das alles
politik ist regeln setzen grenzen setzen
grenzen setzen ist auch verbietet das
ist das machen alle parteien das macht
jedes gesetz das heißt dass vortag
falsche richtung sagt war eine antwort
auf die frage sind sie ein verbot spart
und deshalb ist dieser verbots
parteigeschichte einfach ein klischee im
wahlkampf gewesen das haben die anderen
hart gefahren und jetzt sollen wir
vielleicht mal zusammensetzen und eine
lösung sei sie aber trotzdem habe ich
das gefühl tut mir leid also das jetzt
nicht nur wahlkampf wenn wenn vertreter
der fdp hier sitzen und genau diese
diese platte spielen sozusagen ja die
sowieso beschreiben sie das ja so
gefühlt dann habe ich schon immer das
gefühl da geht schon auch um eine echte
haltung die dahinter steht dass die
frage glaubst du daran dass du einfach
nur einen ganz großen rahmen setzt
ordnungspolitischen rahmen setzt und
dann macht der rest die wirtschaft dann
kommt die große entfesselung dann dann
findet das alles stadt oder sagst du was
auf wir machen regeln was ehrlich gesagt
wenn wir uns mal tief in die augen
gucken einfach nur ein nettes wort für
verbote ist und machen uns darüber dass
ist doch ein fundamentaler und darf ich
mal darf ich mal zwei beispiele sagen es
gibt nämlich in dem was christian
lindner jetzt gesagt hat und wie gesagt
wir sind gerade in der findungsphase und
wollen vertrauen aufbauen aber da gibt
es ja zwei fehler dass eines dieser
frontal stellung und das zweite ist am
ende sagt er und die anderen wollen ja
einfach alles gleich machen sind alles
gleich machen fanatiker so ist das jetzt
geht es geht eigentlich ums klima und
man nutzt also ich ja so einfach
beispielhaft vorwurf hat sie nutzen das
klima aber das ding ist sozialismus oder
gleich den kommunen
wir wollen den sozialismus die anderen
aber wollen manchester kapitalismus das
kommen muss bis zum ende der welt werfen
aber da kommen wir nicht so hin zu einer
regierung in diesem land da bleiben wir
bis am ende der tage wahlkampf machen
irgendjemand muss ja regieren und die
probleme lösen ich will aber zwei
beispiele sagen schule wir haben
jahrelang schulkrieg in diesem land
gehabt ihnen über die form der
hauptschule grundschule hauptschule
realschule gymnasium
versus gesamtschule und irgendwann haben
wir gesagt leute es gibt gute
realschulen und schlechte gymnasien
lasst uns darüber reden was in der
schule passiert stadt dass wir diesen
krieg einfach fortsetzen dass er so eine
lösung wenn man einfach mal alle
zusammen kriegen kann mit der ideologie
zweites beispiel was jetzt aber sicher
nicht ganz so einfach wird tempolimit so
essig kann jetzt schon lange erklären
warum tempolimit sinnvoll wäre und
gleichzeitig für eine andere seite
dessen kritische wort verbieten und so
weiter und so fort ich habe noch niemand
getroffen von der rechten seite der der
republikanischen partei in den usa wäre
sagte tempolimit ist eigentlich das ende
meiner freiheitlichen rechte sollten es
einfach debatten wird die mal
runterholen muss und wann man argumente
fahren muss und nicht darüber reden muss
dass da das weltbild des anderen person
probleme was sie wissen doch selbst nur
wo man kann genau solche details kann
man doch hoch jádson wirklicher zu einer
echten fundamental position und sagen
worauf das ist das symbol an dem wir
festmachen ob wir mit euch können oder
so also umgekehrt doch auch wenn sie in
diese koalitionsverhandlungen unter dem
diese koalition jetzt eintreten und es
gibt kein tempolimit wohin doch das
klima angeblich so furchtbar furchtbar
herzen liegt und sich jedoch bei ihrer
basis nicht mehr blicken zu lassen wenn
sie ohne tempolimit aus diesen
verhandlungen rauskommen dann bei ihnen
also das was die leute wollen haben
wollen natürlich ein tempolimit sehen
aber das entscheidende ist doch dass die
leute sehen dass wir die klimaziele re
ich weiß aber ist das für sie eine
andere kundin um es mal so zu sagen er
entweder klappt das oder nicht erstens
wenn man vor verhandlungen erklärt was
per se nicht mehr geht dann hast du
gemacht beim thema steuern ja ich weiß
ich weiß ich trotzdem wird es so sein
dass natürlich bei verhandlungen die
themen die man selber markiert hat dem
anderen auf den tisch gelegt hat
natürlich ein gefundenes fressen sind
für die andere seite aber entscheidend
wird sein dass kann ich glaube ich ich
bin jetzt nicht der geschäfte meiner
partei aber ich kann versprechen meiner
partei nimmt alles mit was am ende dazu
führt dass in toto die klimaziele die
deutschland angenommen hat völkerrechts
gibt verbot ok auch angenommen weil es
interessant ich kann ein anderes
beispiel sagen wo ich sagen würde wenn
das nicht kommt wird es nicht
funktionieren das wird wissenschaftlich
nicht funktioniert ist der kohleausstieg
da gibt es überhaupt
auseinandersetzungen aber aber mit der
spd weil die spd will 2038 aussteigen
wir wollen 2030 aussteigen wenn wir
dahin die mathematische politische mitte
nehmen wenn wir die klimaziele trotzdem
noch erreichen deshalb ein
wissenschaftler schon mal ganz kurz die
tempolimit geschichte das heißt das ist
etwas spüre ich jetzt hier dass das ist
verhandlungsmasse es ist nicht
verhandlungsmasse wir wollen das
knallharte aber am ende ist ja klar nein
nicht ein bisschen knallhart
entscheidend ist dass am ende die
klimaziele erreicht werden wollen ja ja
das ist ja egal ob es knallhart wollen
wenn es am ende nichts wird dann war er
war mit knallhart durch wir können auch
sozusagen das ding ist kompromiss ist
der wesenskern der demokratie ich will
nicht dass darum dass der symbole mit
wegkommt wir wollen das knallharte haben
und auch diskutieren und verhandelt und
hoffentlich auch durchsetzen sie können
uns so wichtig ja der spaß ist uns sehr
wichtig ist es super wichtig ist aber
nicht wichtig genug aber es ist eine
maßnahme von vielen und klimaziele zu
erreichen okay ich merke ich krieg sie
da nicht an ich will noch mal weil ich
leiten wollen das wirklich es ist kein
wird wir wollen ja wirklich besser aber
das dass der kompromiss an dem punkt ist
das dann nicht so ein faules ei das das
da das ist doch genau das was zb diese
junge leute die sie da jetzt haben die
wollen das nicht wir haben die faxen
dicke und isolieren sie denen das sie
können ihnen doch sagen hier gibt es
andere möglichkeiten gibt alternativ
welche gibt die möglichkeit dass sie
erst mal eine sanierung und bass ich
alle sauer hat alles wieder so lange
also ich will noch mal die grundsatz
tausende argument ist das eine geht eine
gleichmacherei die sie betreiben oder
also ich will den unterschied man
versuchen zu definieren zwischen den
liberalen und ihn ich habe das auch mal
öffentlich gemacht zum ärger einiger bei
ihnen also bei uns das leitmotiv die
freiheit wir schränken sie ein wenn es
im sinne des gemeinwohls notwendig essen
also hier wenn der markt nicht
funktioniert müssen regeln er okay wir
müssen regeln abgas regeln für autos
haben tempolimit 130 bitte ich will
diese regeln vergaben im betreten das
gelände so machen sie tempolimit 130 für
sie okay
gibt es kein anderes
koalitionsverhandlungen in der sie
trauen sich auch nicht merkt dass das
ist ja das ist ein mittel verstehen sie
aber sie würden das nicht an sagte ich
würde jetzt schon auf die grundsatzfrage
gehen auf die kulturellen unterschiede
die sie haben ja wie ist das mit den mit
dem staat und dem markt ja das vertrauen
wir dem staat an welche schutzfunktion
als er ich habe eben das klima und fr
zitiert da ist eine schutzfunktion
definiert der künftigen generation und
die schutzfunktion des status haben wir
hautnah erlebt in der bi nicht wahr also
wie tarieren wir das aus dass die
staatseingriffe nicht zu weit gehen dass
wir immer auch wirklich sehr aufmerksam
verfolgen ist das unbedingt notwendig
ist das effizient auch bei der inneren
sicherheit mein ganzes leben lang habe
ich dagegen kämpften die bürgerlichen
freiheiten eingeschränkt zu sehen wo es
nicht notwendig mal also dieses
spannungsverhältnis zwischen staat und
selbstverantwortung ist da und das ist
auch in den verhandlungen da nicht mehr
aber es ist nicht nur über es ist doch
nicht unüberbrückbar
wir müssen das richtige mittel finden
damit ziele zu erreichen noch mal fragen
bevor wir jetzt hier wirklich sozusagen
dann wieder in uns völlig verlieren
handfest sie zitieren dieses urteil sie
sagen das ist eine menschheitsaufgabe
das ist wichtig dass schutz der die
schutzfunktion des staates wir haben
jedes jahr hunderttausende menschen die
alleine in europa an umweltverschmutzung
an den folgen von umweltverschmutzung
sterben was wir sofort morgen machen
könnten das heißt nicht dass ich das
will aber ich sage nur wir könnten es
tun wenn wir das ernst meinen wenn wir
doch alle hier übereinstimmen und sagen
wir müssten co2 ausstoßen verhindern
umweltverschmutzung muss runter das geht
so nicht weiter warum dann kein
tempolimit 130
ich habe aber warum nicht warum kein
tempolimit ich habe darauf keine antwort
wir sind das einzige land auf der welt
was nicht hat aber woran aber sie
könnten unter einer bedingung machen
aber es gibt auch haufenweise andere
dinge die wir auch beschäftigung machen
werden sie wollten es nicht nennen
wir wollen das wirklich sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr mächtig das ist überhaupt
keine frage aber ich will das noch mal
an klar machen wenn wir einzelne punkte
herausgreifen geht und sofort einen
etiketten kleben kompromiss ist parat
dann sehen wir in einer polarisierung
die einen usa gerade massiv zu sehen den
demokratischen diskurs kaputt macht und
das sollten wir einfach alle zusammen
als demokratische partei nicht wir haben
wir haben gerade über robert habe die
spd auch gesprochen roberta b k themen
november 2020 hat er sich bei uns
geäußert zu möglichen koalitionen und
sie sagte mit der spd wird schwierig
robert habeck scheint das anders zu
wollen doch mit der union oder nicht
nein natürlich nicht sie wollen nicht
mit nein
möglicherweise sind wir gezwungen mit
der union das weiß ja keiner ich meine
das haus einer jamaika regierung aber wo
kommt das her mit wem wollen sie denn
dann mit der spd
also wenn sie mich fragen was wollen sie
dann sage ich eine grün geführte
regierung mit den sozialdemokraten okay
weil sie da kanzler werden können
natürlich weil die spd und die grünen
die größten stellt bringen haben aber es
gibt jetzt keine keine sehnsucht nach
der union ganz im gegenteil wo soll die
denn herkommen
soll die bloß herkommt ein
pensionist also
gut also wir sind ja jetzt dabei das
auszuloten nicht also einer muss man
sich um 7 das so ab soll er das sagt ja
ja ja ist festgelegt nicht in eine
richtung
und dollar ist das taktik das weiß ich
nicht das hat damals wirklich so geburt
übrigens als die spd noch bei 15 prozent
steigen also eine völlig ungefährliche
howrse das
stimmt wenn ich das ich erinnere mich
daran was technisch gesehen und ich habe
ihn sofort angerufen hat nämlich gesehen
aber ohne haben trat gefeiert ich fand
das genau richtig das so zu sagen ich
bleibe dabei dass diese aussage richtig
war er sagt in folge sagen wir müssen
regieren
weil wenn man miteinander nicht redet
kriegt man nicht in der demokratie nicht
hin aber das annalena baerbock gesagt
sehr ähnlich die sagt im nächsten teil
wir schicken die cdu in die opposition
und wir werden wie ich es bleibt dabei
ich habe eine maßnahme genannt die
neuralgische ist für den klimaschutz
weil wissenschaftliches schon nicht mehr
denkbar ist wenn wir vor wenn wir nicht
vor zwanzig dreißig aus kohle aussteigen
die klimaziele zu erreichen aber wir
werden trotz wir haben trotzdem die
größere nähe zu den ganzen dramatik
fragen und daher in vielen bereichen
deshalb ist unsere präferenz stets
gewesen mit der spd zu koalieren er hat
gesagt sie hat es im wahlkampf gesagt
wir sagen nach der wahl genial also dank
unserer nähe zur cdu hat ja hat ehrlich
und offen leben doch immer genau dafür
seien der fantasie fehlt die fantasie
für eine koalition mit der spd hat er
bis kurz vor der maya und das ist das
wahr ist seiner meinung und die hat da
vertreten hat aber immer gesagt dass ich
einmal dann wenn jetzt geholfen muss ja
ich meine er kann das war da gibt es ja
die vorwegnehmen nicht und er hat das
nicht ausgeschlossen und kluger weise
seine strategie war richtig er hat sich
bisher auch konsequent so verhalten und
er wird jetzt ausloten und sie werden
ausloten was geht was geht mit dem an
was geht mit dem anderen es wäre ja und
klug mal aus unserem interesse der fdp
diese option cdu ein worauf zugeben ja
sie brauchen die installation ist daher
auch essays und die große cdu nur noch
als verhandlungsmasse und es hängt aber
nicht um diese idee umsetzen sie die
richtig was aus dem häuschen die nähe
ist natürlich war die nähe ist natürlich
da hat das herrlich gespielt sie haben
die frage ist natürlich was macht die
cdu das mit ihrem kandidaten nicht wenn
du das ist dort das problem das drama
das übrigens ich frage mich auch irland
sich aber zweimal erlebt wie die spd
ihren künstlern gestürzt hat ja zwei mal
1982 die fdp sich auch nicht gut
verhalten
ich habe damals mit die fdp hat sich ja
auch vater bei der wende war nicolai
bitte waren sie doch dabei war ich dabei
aber ich habe damals er mit den jungen
sie haben geholfen hat eine seite bei
der spd mit mit schröder beispielsweise
und die haben gesagt wir haben heute das
ja nicht fortsetzen ihr fehlt uns noch
in den rücken er gibt doch und den gegen
unseren gegnern in der fdp die argumente
in die jahren wir wollen schmitt weg
haben ja das war und das zweite war
schröder 2005 vorgezogene neuwahlen noch
das vertrauen seiner partei nicht hatte
ich unterstelle jetzt der spd nicht dass
das noch einmal passiert aber was
passiert in den fraktionen das ist
einmal der cdu nun vor allen dingen was
passiert denn da ihrer meinung
die sind ja ein also ihr parteikollege
wolfgang kubicki sagte gestern
glaubliche wollte die woche wird zu ende
gehen ohne dass die browser eintrifft
aber natürlich
sehr sagte laschet wird das ende dieser
woche ja politisch nicht überstehen wird
meister teufel was mit ihm was er ist
schwer angeschlagen wissen wir alle aber
das ist doch nicht unsere sache die
börse in die zukunft gucken und wenn sie
nicht regierungsfähig sind die cdu dann
erübrigt sich das nicht so und aber die
option ist noch da und meines erachtens
ist es sind jetzt die die überlegungen
müssen die muss die überlegung sein wie
kriegen wir gemeinsam
dass das schiff ins wasser ja das stimmt
und das bedeutet dass wir eine
riesenaufregung brauchen und wie fanden
sie in dem zusammenhang dass jetzt schon
mal die reviere markiert werden dass man
sagt ich werde dann finanzminister und
robert haben zumindest wird es so
kolportiert sollte ich werde an
vizekanzler der kommunen trittin und
sagt nicht euer ernst schon wieder im
hinterzimmer so ausgeruht also wie
fanden sie den vizekanzler am gleich hat
sich die frage mit dem finanzminister
wie fanden sie das robert habe hätte ich
gesagt er wird zukünftig das wird aber
kolportiert es wird immer cool ist über
das ist doch das normalste aber nur
bitte ich bin jetzt seit 15 jahren im
gelangen am tag nach der wahl geht die
schnitzeljagd darauf los was wird da
gibt es jeden tag 5.000 solche meldungen
es zu welch leid aber ich komme da nicht
mehr mit und und und warum sagt jürgen
trittin dann sowas und wird auch
wirklich ärgerlich und sagt das macht
ihn nicht noch mal ihr beiden er meinte
annalena baerbock und robert habeck dass
ihr im hinterzimmer aus klingelt wer was
wird ich habe alle diese drei leute die
letzten tage sehr sehr oft gesehen wir
haben sehr viel darüber geredet und das
zitat von jürgen trittin kriege ich
jetzt nicht mehr wörtlich zitiert ist
die beiden parteivorsitzenden machen
einen vorschlag und die partei stimmt
dem zu oder auch nicht das war immer so
was wieder so sein das ist doch nichts
anderes als das was ich gesagt habe und
das ist das was was einfach die prozedur
ist es war bei der kanzlerkandidatur
genau dasselbe haben sie haben vorschlag
gemacht unter parteitages am ende
entschieden robert habeck will nicht
vizekanzler werden das weiß ich nicht
ich wahrscheinlich will er das und ich
habe keine ahnung was wir miteinander
gesprochen hatte aber die wir werden der
unterschied so zum frühjahr es die
werden am ende ein riesen also sollten
wir in die verlegenheit einer
regierungsbeteiligung kommen werden sie
am ende ein riesen personaltableau
vorlegen weil sehr viele entscheidungen
getroffen werden müssen und dass wir da
geht es vor allen dingen auch um diese
beiden die wir da im bild sehen herr
baum ganz kurz christian lindner hat
vorher schon sehr deutlich gesagt ich
würde dann gerne finanzminister werden
das verstehe ich aber zunächst einmal
hier zur tortur in grün ja warum seid
ihr denn so nervös eine solche äußerung
14 aufstand wir
immer nervöser
unruhe da ich meine sehr gut ich finde
dass ich finde das nicht findet das
wirklich nicht zielführend und ich meine
der lindner habe ich habe mich auch
gefragt ist das richtig dass er sich da
anmelden sagt wenn ich biete ich bin da
nicht ich kann das machen nicht
irgendwas macht so da muss man jetzt
oben fällt sehen da gab es drei
kanzlerkandidaten die dauernd irgendwo
auftaucht und da hat er sich
strategischer ich muss ins spiel kommen
und ich komme ins spiel mit meiner
kompetenz die kompetenz der fdp war die
hauptkompetenz im wahlkampf die finanz
wirtschafts politik das genau ist die
kernkompetenz von christian lindner
finanzminister zu werden und die
kompetenz wollte er durch diese aber das
unterstützen welcher ist das wo genau
ist die kernkompetenz von christian
lindner in finanziell die bedienung ist
der partei der partei steht er im fall
der von christian lindner mit dem
wahlprogramm nach gute hat der hat sich
ja x-mal dazu geäußert in den enden
diskussion hat ja zum finanzpolitischen
und wirtschaftsfragen hatte er ja
auskunft gegeben schon kompetente
automatisch also ich meine es können wir
beide ja auch tun kann sind jetzt werden
sie sehen wenn wenn er das amt haben
sollte nicht dann werden noch sehen
lassen will das ist aber er hat er hat
sich darauf vorbereitet er hat dazu dass
sich geäußert er hat
klare worte gesagt zu finanzpolitischen
zukunft die müssen war handelt werden
und er hat die fdp mit diesem thema
sichtbar gemacht dass er im moment habe
ich gedacht verdammt noch mal warum nur
dieses eine thema warum diese einengung
auf steuer steuern werden aber das war
eben in der jetzigen situation sozusagen
die funktion
ich wünsche mir dass er künftig und das
wird auch geschehen dass die
freiheitsbewegung oder die freiheit und
die thematik sich aber es gibt genügend
leute das heißt das heißt um sie von vor
drei minuten zu zitieren das war der
moment an dem die fdp nervös wurde weil
sie nicht mehr statt ja das war diese
durch seine strategie war goldrichtige
dem ok und dann sagt man einfach ich
werde mal finanzminister wir haben uns
also einfach nicht also aber es geht
auch um diese beiden köpfe es geht um
robert habe kristalliner robert abel
wurde ja zwischenzeitlich als
finanzminister gehandelt oder hat sich
durch böse mächte ins spiel gebracht
böse böse journalisten haben dass er
goalie dann kolportiert es wurde
kolportiert mann hatte sich erzählt dass
es wie einen unfall aussehen egal wie
hört mal ganz konkret liegt wie
christian lindner sich zum thema
finanzminister geäußert hat und in dem
zusammenhang auch über tabak
setzt sich um einen spaziergang den eine
tageszeitung mit dem potenziellen
finanzminister robert habeck unternommen
hat der geschätzte kollege h weg führt
dann seine gedanken zur schuldenbremse
aus
nämlich es sei das problem der
schuldenbremse das wort selbst
schulden
im wort schulden stecke ja schuld also
kommt der vorschlag des potentiellen
finanzministers robert habeck lasst uns
nicht mehr von schulden sprechen sondern
von krediten
lassen uns nicht von schulden sprechen
sondern von krediten denn im wort kredit
stecke ja die lateinische wurzel credo
glauben wer an kredit erhalte habe einen
gläubiger also jemanden der ihn glauben
schenkt ich war beeindruckt als ich das
gelesen habe habe mir aber auch gedacht
und das kann ja heiter werden in der
nächsten zeit
realisierte sehr amüsant ja ist ein
brillanter rhetoriker sorgt und dieses
duell dieser beiden ausnahmetalente
finde ich in der deutschen politik also
christian lindner robert habeck das ist
spannend das zu sehen aber er zieht den
komplett in den matsch ich das erklären
da gehört hat
wie gesagt wir haben einen weiten satz
um chinesen aber wir werden das nicht
das gehört sich das
geschmacklich nein herr raum gehört sich
das
heute sagen es ist toll dass sie am
besten wo das ist eine andere sache ja
gern drin das ist die frage die die wir
klären müssen wofür man schulden auch
nicht ich hätte gesagt es gibt schulden
und schulden unterschiedliche
bestimmungen schulden für investitionen
schon für konsum und wie die hat er
damals um und da damit auch
gut es war ein gag wahlkampf und wenn
ich jetzt mal ich wir wollen jetzt mit
dem kuschel nicht übertreiben aber er
sagt das kann ja heiter werden also das
ist schon nicht so weit unter der
gürtellinie aber das ding ist ja eher
sagt schuldenbremse also keine neuen
schulden machen er sagt wir müssen ganz
dringend die steuern so lassen wir sie
sind ja sagt wir müssen ganz dringend
soli abschaffen das heißt alle einnahmen
oder quasi einnahmemöglichkeiten des
staates auf keinen fall mehr und
gleichzeitig sagt er in jeder rede
diesem wahlkampf berechtigterweise
modernisieren digitalisierung
infrastruktur nach vorne bringt und
irgendwann ich habe herzlich das abitur
aber auch ich komme nicht hinterher wie
das mathematisch gehen und das bin ich
jetzt sehr dafür ja ich weiß dass er
privat sagt den wahlkampf
um die zukunft des landes ist dieser
frage der steuern ihr wochen sicherlich
die größte das größte hindernis zwischen
zwischen grün und und liberal und wir
werden uns zusammensetzen müssen aber
dieses permanente niert das wird nicht
richtig gut also ich setze wenn ich sage
dass der wahlkampf fort das sage ich das
können sie beim beginn einer
koalitionsverhandlung alles austauschen
und dann muss was anderes richtig da
muss der kompromiss
sonst geht dann schüttelte er den
aussehen was weiß ich habe mich da nicht
einmischen also möchte denen auch nicht
vorschreiben mandat
behälter stets würden hochinteressiert
noch an der wie auch fragen fragen die
sie noch und rufen sie angehören zu ja
gut man sieht wo sie waren ja manchmal
sehr ungnädig mit christian lindner
gegangen heute hätten sie mal die
gelegenheit ihnen ausführlich zu loben
ja gut ich habe es ja schon getan ist
sondern eine gute strategie gemacht hier
zu bei ok reicht reicht ist das ist
ich habe
das bei ihnen oft gesagt ich hab ich
nach jamaika kritisierten ich habe auch
in der zwischenzeit kritisiert bald wie
möglich das gefühl hat der fdp hatten
kompass verloren sie war aber bei fünf
prozent das hat sich aber verändert ich
möchte jetzt dass die fdp auf die ganze
breite ihrer ihrer
freiheits themen bürgerrechte und
umweltschutz da sind als auch segler
macht und dann gibt es gute leute auch
neue leute genau